and so our future recipes will be in
accordance with FDA regulations look
according to our YouTube analytics our
viewers don't even want these grisly
recipes they want to fun Halloween
recipes that they can share with their
friends check out these things that we
saw on pentagram we've got a cowl
pretzels strawberry ghosts pudding
pumpkins like that's what they want to
see Gordon Gordon are you listening are
you serious
we are the walk
welcome to this secret episode of the
walking dead were cooking another recipe
all before Dave gets back from the
meeting roaring car keep raw rights hey
Gordon I was always wondering what it
would be like to eat something that
isn't quite dead while Courtney I've got
just that thing preheat to 350 degrees
then nether flour cocoa baking soda salt
sugar cream milk here vanilla extract
like a rice and it's pronounced licorice
ah Dave just in time to lay the eggs you
know you missed the board meeting this
morning didn't you see I was there the
Julie's do the cars production intro
nobody cares about your stupid company
days seriously Gordon I've had just
about enough of you someone woke up on
the wrong side of the 3-bedroom condo
complete with jacuzzi today we're gonna
need to mix it for this Oh baby brave
and even better three months later
mm-hmm
board meeting this morning you would
know that didn't meet FDA regulations oh
shut up Dave all right
we're gonna make butter sugar
and now for our next thing we're gonna
have a very special guest help us
everybody give a warm hearty welcome to
Chris hey Chris how you do little Corden
and welcome to the show
Chris it's gonna help us beat yeah take
it away
hell yeah that's how you beat some eggs
zombie style thanks Chris
moving on now let's add some creep milk
and food coloring oh thank you Chris
thank you Chris Chris
oh I know where I was for a minute I
feel good though oh thanks for coming on
the show now I'm done okay once your
mixture is good and domestically abused
scoop the battery I mean better into the
liners we're gonna open these for about
20 minutes which means we have enough
time for a quick round of aim
the rules are simple I'm gonna feed Dave
here one of my creations if you can
guess what it is correctly I'll let him
go
is there any reason why my hands are
tied behind shut up and eat this is
spicy oh yes okay
what did you give me no no no I'm afraid
it's not milk Dave it's a Cuban ghost
pepper oh we did it become ghosted
they're alive
now make sure you give him time to cool
before adding the frosting
all right normally I like to make my own
frosting but I think Dave will
appreciate this frosting from Gillette
now for my favorite part of the process
filling the cupcake now the recipe calls
for food coloring but I prefer real
human blood because I need my iron
supplement it just tastes better
all right now into surgery I go now take
some like or ice and stitch them back
together now while you can wait for a
well-timed lightning strike I prefer to
use a taser nice color
oh sorry Dave
no Corden ha yo you could have killed it
with that pepper and now you're tasing
people you're out of control
is this your taser well you're gonna
have to have a very serious conversation
about your future with this show oh my
bad consider this my apology
oh okay thank you
thanks for watching
the walking dead remember to subscribe
more dangerously good treats leave it in
the comments remember try these things
in your own kitchen at your own home No
what what's this you're not going to see
the next time because your fires fire
aah now